over these last few weeks stay-at-home
orders of turned America's densest and
most vibrant cities into virtual ghost
towns but for one well-known
photojournalist here in New York the
shutdown created a unique chance to
document the city that never sleeps as
it's never been seen before
brook silva-braga met him on the runway
by his own count George Steinmetz has
climbed into a helicopter to photograph
New York 40 times for New York City a
helicopter is really the ultimate tool
this 2015 book New York air captured the
color energy and scope of America's
biggest city from sunbathers in Central
Park to taxis crowding the avenues what
do you expect today I expect to see a
city change I think we'll see subtle
differences but you know when you go up
in the air you just find things that's
part of the fun of it his discoveries in
the air have made Steinman's one of the
world's best-known aerial photographers
his fifth book the human planet is out
this month but most times he doesn't
work from a helicopter
George's interest in the world's most
remote places
spurred the creation of the world's
lightest flying machine
a motorized Paraguay I wanted to do some
flying in the Sahara and there were no
aircraft to hire out there I had to
bring my own and I had to have something
that didn't use an airfield
let me get aerial photos in places that
had never been seen from the air before
but paragliders are not practical or
legal in New York so this past Tuesday
Steinitz and pilot Nate Lovett took an
open-air chopper on a once unthinkable
path to the city passes over LaGuardia
Steinman's snapped the tarmac all but
deserted crossing into midtown Manhattan
they circled over Rockefeller Plaza the
way you are and then you can cut in 2014
George had captured this image of a
crowded observatory and ice skaters
eight hundred feet below when it's full
of people it's alive it's like this boys
a little ants on top but there were no
ants today and then you look down below
a Rockefeller Center and like you know
the ice ring house there was just total
dead zone it looks like construction
site when I worked in my book I was
trying to photograph the life of the
city and that was what was really
interesting is how the humans were
involved in the city and their their
spatial relationships and where they
were and where they weren't but today
it's nobody there six years ago movie
goers blanketed Bryant Park this week it
was as a vacant as the stretch of 6th
Avenue beside it the bustling rooftop
restaurant on Fifth Avenue
now a place to stack chairs and benches
until something changes
and the famous snarled a traffic of the
Lincoln Tunnel Steinmetz captured the
crawl between New York and New Jersey
back in 2014 and then again Tuesday at
6:45 p.m. usually rush hour just
aesthetically as a photographer was it
more beautiful to shoot less beautiful
it's kind of spooky I mean I'm not like
not super suits or anything but it's
just kind of like it's kind of like a
haunted city yeah I feel like you're
going to futuristic move everybody left
it's very odd really it's not a very
good picture it's kind of depressing to
be honest it's just like the city is
such a vital you know thriving city and
it just looks very just kind of turned
in itself it's in paralysis with so much
missing assignments looked for what had
been added got it go forward here left a
cluster of white Hospital tents dotting
the green of Central Park it's run by
the evangelical group Samaritan's Purse
they more often work in war zones and on
the Hudson River the comfort the Navy
hospital ship with a thousand beds and
just a few dozen patients George circled
around it time and time again your
circle and circle circular circle after
the third or fourth circle what were you
like okay one more circle and this is
what I hope to see when you get the
right picture Brooke it's like you get
like what for my calls like a full gasm
you know you get this kind of written
into brain shock is like ooh you see
something this yeah you see it and it's
just like you get that and I was I felt
that I was close to that got it go
forward here more than the left
helicopter they don't like to hover
little things they hover but they always
like to keep this smooth to keep moving
so you kind of do a pass yeah want to be
a little further a little left little
right little up-down it's always each
one's a little different
what does hover is a drone and Steinmetz
uses them too at sunrise last Tuesday
piloted over Hart island the cemetery
where New Yorkers without family or
money are laid to rest in unmarked
graves as New York boards filled in
recent weeks the pace of burials there
increased
along with some tough questions about
Hart island it's a very somber place and
it's there over a million people buried
there it's a mass grave and it's very
depressing NYPD officers soon found
Steinman's in a Bronx parking lot and
asked for his memory card which he
refused you were out there flying a
drone which you're not allowed to do in
New York City there seem to be a big
response to that yeah it was very
curious because the the the the police
who came over in and confiscated my
drone they weren't local cops
those guys were sent out to do that by
the city and not because it was
endangering anyone but because they
didn't want people to see what was going
on there we have enough fuel to go over
time but Tuesday ended with steam it's
lingering above Manhattan let's go back
voting freely over a frozen city yeah we
made about 10 passes back and forth 20
looking at the avenues and different
kind of times of light and it was
looking up I think it was like third
Avenue and I could see the Chrysler
Building and the city was all just
really dark with this little line of all
the red lights coming down the Avenue it
was just like an empty challenges by red
lights for once the city at the end of
george's lens seemed as still as a
photograph for CBS this morning saturday
brook silva-braga New York